but you've got you know rules for thee
and not for ds as in democrats because
there are a number of democrat mayors
and governors and members of congress
and people running for congress that
image right there is of stacey abrams
she's in uh she's at glenwood elementary
she's talking to her kids there
about her new kids book notice she's the
only person not messed up the principal
tweeted this out and then there was
immediate blow back from republicans and
it's like hey wait a minute where's the
mask there are masked mandates in that
school why is she breaking the rules
well and when the principal tweeted it
out excited that she was coming to the
school which is right outside of atlanta
then she quote posted it or reaped
whatever it is
and reposted it and then you know said
oh it was a wonderful time it was
spectacular delightful and outstanding
well then she got so much heat for it
for not wearing a mask but yet all those
little fours and five-year-olds behind
her have to wear a mask but yet she
doesn't so because there were four
pictures that the principal posted three
of them she was not wearing a mask so
yesterday morning the principal's
twitter was deactivated and abram's
tweet was deleted right yeah so by the
way we just got word uh they're gonna
announce today the new york no mass as
of first week in march
so they've got two more weeks new
jersey's about the same yeah toss the
mask in the garden the kids no matter
well yeah i think it's for schools it's
for schools that's the key i think the
15th is when things change here in new
york city anyway speaking of new york
city
congressman jamal bauman
from new york
was up at new rochelle high school and
he was he too posing with students and
the kids are all messed up and he is not
now keep in mind new york man's massive
priority is in all public schools in the
state and new rochelle enforces it but
going back to uh stacy abrams her
spokesperson had to defend her you know
why was she breaking the rules and her
spokesperson said this stacy trusts
science and supports masking in schools
as it's the current cdc recommendation
she wore a mask to the event and removed
it at the podium so she could be heard
by students watching remotely and for
photos but only with folks who were
messed so in other words hey
special exemption she's going to be able
to take it off because she's speaking
listen a rule is a rule so it should
apply to everybody at all times right
unless they know they're not they know
the rule is stupid and they're not going
along with it and they're getting caught
right so jamal brown back to him the
congressman from new york he posted that
picture was from january 31st when he
was with the nine kids at um or nine
students at new rochelle high school but
then three days later he tweeted out on
february 3rd make sure to mask up stay
safe and get boosted then on february
5th he was at westchester jewish council
gala seen without a mask when he put a
picture on on twitter and so when we
asked him for a comment why are why are
you telling us to mask up and you're not
and everyone else says and he did not
respond yeah oakdale california is a big
movement these kids are not going to
school in mass they're told if you're
not going to come to school in mass just
turn around and the oakdale joint
unified school system don't come in
they're going to try to get in they're
going to get tossed out
in washington state the same thing these
kids they're in 10th 11th grade they
know it's dumb they know the hypocrisy
that's happening they know the risks
that are out there they know if they
have underlying conditions they're tired
of being walking around with this
oppressive mask over over their face
that doesn't do anything on top of that
and they're finally standing up speaking
out i look for that to really get
momentum how about eric adams he's never
going to be twice right he said all the
kids have to be massed up at schools
when you're on school property even if
you're out on the playground running
around you still have to wear a mask but
yet he was seen on arthur avenue which
is the italian area up in the bronx in
little italy up there and he was seen
without masking even though there are
indoor mass mandates in new york jeremy
hunt is running for congress down in the
great state of georgia and had this
observation about what we've seen these
democrats do and you know the hypocrisy
of
what's going on with these rules here he
is earlier on the show
it doesn't matter if you are republican
democrat parents are pissed off at the
covet hypocrisy i mean as we're
campaigning for congress and going
around the district here and parents are
telling me look they're sick of the
masked mandates i mean even that's me
i'm a father father of a two-year-old
little girl i'm sick of putting the mask
on my daughter just going to the
airplane going on an airplane these days
i mean it's got out of control i think
this november voters are going to show
up to the polls and send a loud and
clear message to the democrat party that
they have completely missed it
well i think everybody's frustrated and
ready to take them off
he's got a two-year-old they just have
to change the rules for everybody and
not be so selective about allowing
certain people to do it right because
they don't work uh they only they only
keep you safe by two percent they they
said that at johns hopkins they said
natural immunity should count they also
said the the clampdowns the lockdowns
all these preventative measures save
point zero two percent uh lives and if
you counter that with how many the
emotional and actual educational damage
done to these kids it does not add up
but nobody's covering that although i
did see a little bit of change on cnn at
least they're asking questions about the
hopkins study to other people
well it's really hard when you're a
parent and your child's learning to read
and they need to see that the impossible
the mouth of the teacher while they're
teaching them sounds and sight words and
for two years they can't and you ask any
teacher they say they have seen kids
falling behind every child falling
behind because of all of this so you
have to weigh out your risks right
that's a learning delay and so when they
go back to school and there's no mask
it's like hey this is so much easier it
was so good not to have anthony on
television this week get there as
quickly as possible i went on brian
kilmeade i want you to do me a favor i
want you to click to subscribe to the
fox news youtube page this is the only
way that i know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on fox you can get it
all here on youtube so subscribe right
now